[Applause]
happy Thursday America
tonight's monologue crime and punishment
I just came up with that title
yeah it would be a good one for a book
huh
first let's address FBI agent Steve
friend who was suspended after he made
allegations in a whistleblower complaint
he was stripped of his gun and badge and
removed from the Daytona Beach FBI field
office
that sounds like fun getting stripped at
the Daytona Beach field office
but I guess as far as the FBI is
concerned he's been unfriended
see what I did there with his name
because his name's friend
I think that's a courtesy laugh on your
part but I'll let it go
now or you can keep doing it are you
okay but don't you remember the
Whistleblower protection act that was
such a big deal when all the anonymous
leakers were coming after Trump now it
gets ignored like Jamie listow's Tinder
dating profile
very lonely guy
laughing through the tears
friend was declared absent without leave
because he wouldn't take part in a SWAT
raid that he considered excessive force
against the January 6 folks accused of
misdemeanors in a way it's like being
punished for refusing to take part in a
home invasion
but because Fran pissed off the wrong
people he was gone faster than you can
say reliable sources with Brian stelter
never over it's never over I'm never
letting it go I'm never letting him go
just gonna hug his little round body
so they bury me in the same coffin which
will be a piano case
remember that guy his complaint
underscored what we've been saying for a
few years the FBI doj IRS AOC and every
other three-lettered governmental outfit
deserving of four letters has been
encouraged to exaggerate the threat of
domestic terrorism the demand for
violent white terrorists somehow exceeds
the supply so they have to make them up
it's like a scaled up version of Jesse's
millet's hoax except this is way easier
because unlike a typical fake hate crime
you don't even need the victims you just
need the amorphous threat and the FBI
will fill in the blanks now maybe some
of these threats exist but it's not like
they ever find them they're like women
in a Brian Kilmeade makeout story
sad isn't it
I wish he would just stop it's
embarrassing for everybody involved
so just like people who paid their
student loans this agent a respected
12-year veteran of the FBI and a SWAT
team member was punished for doing the
right thing
now if the other side does the wrong
thing then it's another story in North
Dakota which is a state cat
a fiend admits to running down a
teenager over a political dispute and
he's currently out of jail
he murdered the kid and he's out of jail
apparently he's not a Flight Risk which
I guess is defined as he won't run over
people with a plane
according to authorities the alleged
killer used his truck to mow down Kaylor
Ellingson who the fiend claims was part
of an unnamed Republican extremist group
you know I tried to search for this
story yesterday and it's amazing there
was less coverage than Michael Moore in
a belly shirt
think about that for a while
yeah
now let's flip the script imagine Donald
Trump making the same speech Joe Biden
did that Bonkers won in front of Satan's
Grotto
and then a left-wing teenager is
murdered by a Trumper the word
incitement would be shouted faster than
you could say Charlottesville
funny it's not the case here no one's
screaming you've got the blood on your
hands Mr President or the same thing to
his like-minded Pals in the media
because it's the media who usually does
that sort of screaming
let's go to Joe Biden for comment
[Music]
uh Mr President thank you
at the end of such a momentous event
the word thank you seems kind of
inadequate but for all the Millions
whose lives will be saved for the
communities where life will be
transformed thank you so thank you
President Biden
yeah
once again once again he's wandering and
asking anybody's seen my imaginary puppy
that's who he blames the poop on
matter to the media because the Dead kid
might be conservative but deplorable
he's one of the domestic threats so
perhaps you know he had it coming that's
how it works today can you imagine
anybody on the air at Fox ignoring the
girl who was killed at Charlottesville
or ignoring that story completely
but who knows maybe MSNBC will do this
story only after they discover that the
murderer is white
but this is why as Maniacs in New York
attack people with axes and machetes
slashing women in subways clobbering the
elderly for their wheelchairs the New
York AG is going after the biggest
domestic terrorist of them all Donald
Trump I haven't seen someone abuse their
office like that since Matt Lauer
if you're watching Matt I know you
didn't expect that joke
it's like enough already it's been four
years
no it hasn't
so yeah the during the ugliest deadliest
crime wave in recent history Leticia
James is Prosecuting the Trump family
for allegedly over appraising their
property to get better loans from Banks
yep he might have taken some of the
largest banks to the cleaners he
shouldn't be prosecuted he should be
receiving the presidential medal of
freedom
but as everyone knows you can appraise
your property it doesn't matter the
banks do their own appraisal one is
deliberately High and the other is low
but more important that this is the AG's
concern putting politics over people's
misery women are getting raped but
Leticia James is looking out for
Deutsche Bank
that is some feminist
but it makes me wonder why aren't we
liberals can we see how much easier our
lives would be if we just faked it as a
lib and pretended to be compassionate
while screwing over people left and
right I mean nowhere else is there more
faking going on other than Jamie's
honeymoon
it should be so much better
we wouldn't be targeted we wouldn't lose
our jobs we can even kill people who
upset us I'd say if you can't beat them
join them but I'd rather live in a world
where you can just beat them and I mean
in the voting booth
just make sure you can pull that curtain
Shut and muffle the screams
[Applause]
let's welcome
tonight's guests his pronouns are has
and been
actor writer and comedian Jamie listow
foreign
McDowell
her smile makes me tear up and smile is
the name of her pepper spray Foxy's
contributor cat Tim
and he once lit a cigar off a volcano my
massive sidekick in the nwa's world
Television Champion Tyrus
Danny welcome back uh being um so alone
most of the time I assume you've come up
with a number of jokes how care to
estimate how many jokes you have for
this particular segment I would say uh
maybe three to five okay three to five
it is yeah uh so what have you what do
you make of this monologue what are your
thoughts there's some stuff that makes
me angry in the monologue I mean there's
a kid that died he was run you know it
makes me the angriest obviously it's a
tragedy but the fact that he left this
dude yes you know like maybe he could
have saved maybe he did something in a
moment of anger but then he still left
and fled the scene I think that's what
really bothers me because I feel like we
can argue about politics or whatever but
at some point when there's like human
life on you know like honest to God I
feel like even if Brian stelter was
falling into a canyon I would reach over
and we'd both die
[Laughter]
that was worth it well that was a good
line like where is he going where is he
going yeah I didn't know either but then
the guy's sort of claiming like
self-defense which the only way that's
possible is if in the rare instances
that this kid is a Transformer yeah
that's true yeah the guy was in a car
yeah he was in a car it's not fair and
then I props to friend yeah Mr friend he
he's awesome a lot of times it's so hard
to speak out when you know you might
lose your job or you will lose your job
so Props that guy for telling the truth
and I was reading the story and they
were like oh he you know they took his
badge and gun and then they fired him
and I was like that's the right order to
do that
do you know what I mean they have
learned from their mistakes yes isn't it
also like a cool we're up to four jokes
there's one more
um foreign
job when somebody like takes your badge
and gone I mean that's like a cool do I
mean like when I was at jobs they'd be
like hey leave your apron and your
plunger
well done thank you excellent work yes
who can do a stand-up like stand-up mini
set in the middle of a of a serious
topic being alone really increases your
productivity yeah foreign
and rejected by the people you love
don't forget that part
icle focus is Trump
um of course yeah correct would you you
started with Crime and Punishment here
it's crime and eh what are you gonna do
yeah exactly I did think that this
segment was when it because it's a
little tagline was who deserves
punishment so I actually thought I was
gonna like have a moment for an airing
of my grudges because I've been I've
been keeping them for about oh 50 years
now yes you know on number one on the
list the boyfriend who picked up another
woman in front of me at a bar
he's dead now
but I didn't but I didn't kill him
someone did oh but I'm gonna make I
decided I was gonna make up um I'm with
her t-shirts like fugazi fake Lou I'm
with her t-shirts so I keep the popo and
the prosecutors and the federales in my
corner there you go there you go always
thinking ahead that's what we have you
here Dagen yep all right and for my my
hot legs yeah that too that too
cat uh you look at all these government
agencies do we just need to tear them
down and rebuild them yeah we can tear
most of them down and see if we need to
rebuild them yeah I don't think they
don't really do very much uh it is crazy
I mean the story The about from the car
murderer yeah uh everyone's saying it's
crazy that he's out which is true but
also in his court hearing he was arguing
they shouldn't even have bail
and one of the reasons he said he's like
I have a job yes I was like I don't I
don't know about that buddy
you think you're just walking into work
like your boss isn't wondering where you
are he knows yeah
I'm not gonna make it this year yeah I'm
usually
usual stuff like whatever you want to do
no time
you know as long as affect your work
murdering is an exception yes yes but he
but this weird that they've lowered the
standard now so it's just he's not if
you're not a Flight Risk right that's
what they're saying tyrants they're like
it's not a flight so that's how is
somebody not in a Flight Risk who
apparently will hit anything in his way
when he's driving yeah exactly so it
sounds like a pretty dangerous guy
behind the wheel and I keep hearing the
argument over the conversation or
he's a murderer he murdered a kid in
Cold Blood whatever his reason was who
cares yeah I if I wasn't sitting in
front of my truck and little Gutfeld
stood in front of there and
called me the n-word and ran his mouth
and said that in this and I ran him over
with my truck
I'm still a murderer regardless of what
you said might have hurt my feelings
like this is I I don't want to hear the
argument I don't care what he thought I
murdered someone I like how you said
little Greg like well I didn't want him
to be confused with the taller Greg I
just wanted to you know
and you know but it's weird because when
we have victims they don't get Justice
they don't even get public support but
when you don't have victims like the
Trump case which is kind of a problem
right they're suing him
and they're going after him
but they're missing victims right it's
like I'm Jamie you're going to jail for
murder
that's it that's it
it's true that's the whole thing is it
everyone's like what is he saying what
is she saying yeah yeah there's no
victims there's not a banker going Trump
came in smacked me up made me sign this
paper there's no victim when you you
appraise things High to a bank and the
bank doesn't have to take it the bank
does their own they have their own
appraisers it's just the silliest thing
but you're right this is just like the
Biden speech you're creating an idea
that a crime was committed without
having a victim and so now it's just
this thing it's like oh he's going to
jail he's going to jail or oh there's
all these terrorists but there's no
victims no this and this isn't you
always hear that phrase victimist crime
yeah no this crime had no victim all it
did was like whoever does your
negotiation may have their number please
yeah because I would like to get a great
rate from a bank yeah there you go all
right before we go I'll be at Foxwoods
Casino in Connecticut on Saturday
October 1st with special guest uh Jaime
lesue
and Sugarland Texas in November with
someone named cat Tim go to gutfeld.com
for tickets hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else